why would you not fire because when i
got back i'd have to clean
today's topic so preach was in texas
recently but yeah i was with uh colleen
noir
you don't understand how friends it is
you aren't aware he's an attorney a
second amendment advocate and people
think that because we live in canada
we're against guns but it's completely
opposite
all right
oh hold on all right so now i want you
to no
did you pause the video
pause
[Music]
no did y'all hear that sound effect this
is their fight
sounding like lexicon lexington steel
and this
is to go
even further beyond
[Music]
you guys are liking today's video make
sure you like comment okay help us out
with that youtube algorithm there's no
reason not to it's free go i'm getting
my license up here believe it or not you
can get firearms i'm well far in the
process of having the firearm remember
the last steps of having my firearms yep
my my my ppa yeah yeah my brother he's
got his so he's all geared up and it's
not even to go around boasting or doing
any weird stuff just into it
i like going into the range and firing i
like the whole idea of just
there's some people that like yoga
shooting
whether it's crossbow bow
or
guns
is as the same as effect
it's therapeutic but it has the same
effect it's just like martial arts where
you have
to calm yourself in order to perform
where you have to regulate uh your
breath in order to perform well yes you
know you can't be holding all your
breath and then trying to perform it's
not gonna work in martial arts it
doesn't work with guns as well so that's
like a challenge it's good yeah well i'm
gonna just show you guys a little teaser
that he posted so just watch preach in
action
so stop it
millimeters is our thing okay don't call
me weird because i go in meters but then
when it's time to measure bullets you go
melee no don't it's kind of weird no
we're not we're not no we're not doing
this god over here yeah how many inches
is the bullet exactly start shooting
because the thing that happened wet
there is because he was saying oh yeah
so we're going to shoot at 100 yards
okay oh yeah you guys uh you guys yeah
you [ __ ] weirdos
work in with the metric system and i'm
like bruh don't you're not allowed to
call me a weirdo because i work on the
metric system all your [ __ ] is in yards
and feet and fahrenheit
but when you want to count your bullets
it's millimeters stop
okay we're not doing this you're not
calling me a weirdo why are you doing a
millimeter thing because it's more
precise
that's it the metric system is more
precise than the imperial americans are
like that special ed kid
special ed class who don't know what
this special is there for
let me tell you it's not because you
guys are superb it's just because you
guys are different
that's it that's it that's it all right
nobody knows why y'all use fahrenheit
nobody knows why y'all use yards nobody
knows and honestly everyone else just
looks like i'm like
it's unnecessary it's really just
because it's archaic and you don't want
to change that's it if you don't like
change it's okay just like a special
need kid it's all good i understand that
but that's why your bullets are in
millimeters because it's more precise
that's it
looks like
i was just talking to you about that yo
but the way i saw that recall i'm like
this [ __ ] does not have a good problem
my posture was trash because it was the
first time i was shooting that specific
gun with those kind of guns okay well
no the only rifle that i shot was when i
was in the cadet it was the 22 and i was
lying down i was flat on my prone so it
was the the you just really don't have
to so just letting you guys know there's
prone position where it's basically you
guys are on the floor you guys may have
seen this you play call of duty where
you guys are laid plat and your legs are
kind of like like uh how do i it looks
like uh it looks like a horseshoe that's
like
it looks like a horseshoe yeah that's
the best thing you're super flat then
you've got your kneeling position where
it's on one knee and you're kind of just
using your elbow on your thigh muscle
and then you're kind of using that and
then you have obviously your standing
position which was so it's hard to shoot
at this position obviously because you
have the least amount of support
i never shot like that i never shot an
ar i never had shot uh semi-automatic
rifle the only thing i shot was the 22
right which was every time click click
click pow could click
and get i was doing everything it was
not automatic so that was the first time
you feeling that recoil yeah i recall
and because i was not square and i was
not pushing in outside something some
other footage that i got on my gopro
where he told me like he told me how to
really properly uh hold an anger and
yeah and even a handgun it was like my
second time shooting handguns right that
was not that bad that was pretty good i
understood some stuff there but it was
dope colin is
very knowledgeable knowledgeable about
what he does
i appreciate that it was something that
was like you need someone to be in like
you need to be
in you need to be safe feel safe and
everything and stuff it was awesome i
mean of course i'm talking about
firearms
you know one thing that you when you're
on a
when you're on range is like they have
some set rules and they don't play with
them no they don't play with that you
know they'll tell you don't pull your
gun away from them no keep it downrange
don't even point it out and that's like
people who've been doing it for 20 30
years so those rules are in place and
they have to be super strict but also be
informed because you're talking about
people's lives right so he's very good
i've watched his videos before i've been
a fan for a long time because i think
the way he handles things is super super
intelligent and well informed so yeah
you had a good experience if you're for
a gun right you should watch him and if
you're against you should watch it just
to have a better understanding of where
they're coming from it has a good series
of different topics and it makes you
understand better what
people that are for that are guns
advocate uh and second amendment
advocate are for and and what what their
way of thinking is and i understand that
and it makes a lot of sense when he
talks about it when you have an attorney
talking about it it brings down all the
all the the
the wrong things that you thought you
know about about that there's some
people that really have wrong
perceptions about things and that's
exactly that you should definitely watch
this channel if you're curious about it
i believe that every black people
in the state should have a gun
i understand that since that's the
standard you understand what i'm saying
so it was really dope it was really fun
uh and i know exactly what guns i'm
gonna get but i need to i need to i need
to practice on like my stance i'm really
lean back and that's not what i do
you're not trying to be you know fat
there's a lot of things that i learned
that was good i was actually impressed
with how you were handling the shotgun
how much did he instruct you on that
because [ __ ] up the shotgun no
because you could just
it's bad i've seen people handle those
and i'm like oh [ __ ] you're about to
feel that recall but even even then so
how much did he instruct you on that one
specifically it's five minutes but
because i'm not dumb dumb yeah and i
told i was open about the thing that's
the thing good when you go to a gun
range like that don't go with your
attitude and don't go with your ego
i was very open about what i was what i
knew
okay no i never shot that yeah i never
shot that bb guns don't count
okay yeah i shot a b that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] don't count because they're
very it's like whenever you have a bike
and you have a small cc engine it's it's
gonna it's gonna forgive your mistakes
that's the bb gun you know you could do
a lot of [ __ ] on a scooter and you're
not gonna hurt yourself but you
transferred a hayabusa you're gonna get
[ __ ] up it's the same thing so i was
very i was i was very straightforward i
came like my my ego was i don't have it
you go like that for that yeah like i
don't you want to learn i want to learn
so when you want to learn you have to
put your ego aside
so what's this i'm like i don't know i
don't know
i don't know not those guns you should
thought yo bro that's my first time
shooting ar that's my first time showing
this that's my first time shooting his
car
call of duty it's like a bb gun don't
count
it don't count it's not even a bb gun
it's not even a b it's not it's nothing
it's just it doesn't count so i was
really straightforward about what i knew
and what i didn't know and he was able
to better instruct me yeah and of course
there's some work to do on my posture
and everything and stuff but i'll work
on that for other first gun i'm getting
i'm this shameless plug but uh first gun
i'm getting is is the benelli uh benelli
m4 okay oh the uh i'm gonna pretend like
i don't know
i'm being humble by my [ __ ] i don't know
semi-automatic shotgun that was great
but i was impressed though i was
impressed with you handling the shotgun
i thought you did that a lot better than
what i was expecting the stock and i'm
glad that you did that one well because
[ __ ] this would have been harder yeah
but he told me not to put it right there
and i would have the stock a little bit
shorter just to have it closer to me
yeah i'm talking about this car and the
other one mk 111 that he made me shout
out to kalyan yeah when his video comes
out we'll do a full review of it yeah
but yeah i just want to play a little
teaser for you guys and then talk about
guns i'm definitely going back i'm uh
i'm going back and i'm gonna try to go
back in december there you go yeah
that was fun
that's a alaskan oh
revolvers is just cool to me yeah it's
dope it's nice
i'm playing it without the music
but i can keep going but then this video
is gonna get demonetized
and i don't know man he had this thing
about okay now like we shot a couple of
times and he had this thing where he's
like okay
now you shoot as fast as you can like
where yeah
okay look
like a child at a playground so you want
to go can i go
i'll
help you i guess yeah
and then i went it was yeah it was dope
preach you like toys i like you know me
he loves toys and people are surprised
by a lot of this stuff but me i'm all
for people being able to protect
themselves majority of gun owners are
extremely responsible what they do and i
think in places where especially in
places where
um chaos is possible where crime is high
i highly recommend that people have
these kinds of weapons to protect
themselves now you can disagree with it
a lot of people are against these kinds
of ideas um but me coming from where
i've come from uh and the places i've
lived
listen like you didn't get a permit you
just owned a clashing cough or you owned
an 8k you know what i'm saying i
remember holding my first one when i was
what 13
and it's just such a weird feeling it's
cold
like when you grab the weapon for the
full time you just like realize how cold
it is no if it's hot because it's been
working yeah and then the first time i
remember i popped open a magazine and
started like taking out bulls i was like
damn listen this kills a lot of people
you know and so but i understood why it
was necessary because you're talking
about bandits who roam around people who
rob folks murder them at gunpoint um so
in some places these are necessary as a
deterrent to people who would want to
hurt you so uh this is something to keep
in mind there's anything else you want
to say about them nah man shout out to
colin for real it was dope yeah it's
just i'm going back that's for sure for
sure that's gonna be i think that
uh i'm gonna be a long time friend i'm
calling
i'm gonna go back yeah like just before
this i'm supposed to go to my parents
house in florida i'm gonna pass by texas
real quick before i like yo let me go
see kyle in two seconds and i'ma also
say this i felt the necessity to own a
gun far more once i started making money
than before because i started to notice
weird behavior around me so just for
safety purposes it's something i start
to consider not that i could go around
and flaunt it but just to be able to
take care of my own space because
there's people who wish evil things upon
you
you know and once you deal with that a
little bit you're like oh okay i need
this as a deterrent
i need this as a deterrent to violence
which sounds counterproductive but trust
me
having something like that it's like a
mutual assured destruction right where
because they got nukes and you got nukes
then nobody knows
exactly so it's this sometimes it's that
mindset so this is just some of the few
reasons but it's good to see um
responsible gun ownership it's good to
see black folks also taking that into
consideration and doing it legally so i
support all that good stuff yeah exactly
and i think that kind of covers it we'll
do a longer video where we talk about
his experience if you're wondering why i
couldn't be there i had some stuff i'd
take care of back home so i left a
little bit early but the next time i'm
gonna be there oh i hope so what i have
to shoot off the shoot off yeah
definitely damn i mean the guy the guy
that doesn't know how to shoot with the
guy against the guy from the army well
to be fair like when you're in the army
you throw grenades and you fire the
military issued yeah
unless you go to the ranger c7 or c9 c7
c7 c7 c7 so
outside of that you don't use too much
stuff and then if you get to certain
levels of training you'll get to use
pistols and things like that but you
know
did i toss grenades sure did i use the
rifles sure but i wasn't somebody who
liked to go into the range and i'll tell
you why go ahead it's a bit different
when you own the weapon and you got to
take it home the reason being is you got
to clean that [ __ ] yep military was
already stressful enough for me as it
was last thing i want to do is have to
clean a bold clean the whole thing just
like when we're in the field and we're
doing like field exercises i hated it i
hated cleaning my weapon in this shitty
ass tent when i need my sleep
so i used to okay
wait a second let me see if i can tell
the story
is he allowed
nba and [ __ ]
i'll tell this story on the patreon yeah
well this normally we tell stories like
these on the patreon so if you guys want
to see more little short stories from me
and preacher's life but one thing that
[ __ ] us up is that we were eating me
and him italian yeah we're eating a
white dude
certain acts in miami yeah yeah comes to
us is like well i guess i have in my
presence uh preach and call you and we
both look at each other like
what
like
our demographic does not really mix you
were surprised i know but i i was so
i was surprised and he was surprised too
like okay i was i wouldn't be surprised
that's what he said he's like i wasn't
surprised i wouldn't be surprised if you
get recognized or i get recognized but
the one dude recognizes both of us
like whoa but you know what it is it's
like
yeah we have a lot of left-leaning views
but a lot of people don't have never
heard of speak badly about gun ownership
because we don't have any bad views
about it we're actually in favor of it
so people who watch his channel don't
necessarily have an inherent reason to
be against it right so uh and i've also
covered some of his videos we've covered
so i'm a fan so yeah i'm not totally
surprised by that yeah but like both of
us i i'm supportive i was surprised i
was a bride
i was surprised i was like i yeah yeah
i'm not mad at you well listen let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below how do you guys feel about gun
ownership and our stance i was going to
shoot maybe you agree or disagree let us
know in the comments
[Music]
a